[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
la la
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I know you've been waiting
but it's finally here
future of play direct is back
it's been a while and I know you've
missed me
yes Ty it is hard to disagree with the
facts and gamer tirasu you know I can
only speak the truth and the truth can
take wild turns just when I think space
is getting cold your energy warms me
right up good news for us the wait is
over future play direct has entered into
orbit and is reaching out for a cosmic
transmission
so get comfortable but not too
comfortable you need to be on your A
game for what's to come next things are
about to get dangerous
[Music]
so
iled brat with data issues
sent you that huh and you are
I really don't care
it's time for me to get in on the phone
even if we're not yet strong enough for
Rhoda this is still our step forward so
I would like someone like you get in my
way
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
a world of fantasy and dreams awaits you
welcome to the cavern of Dreams
in this 3D platformer you play as Finn a
young dragon whose unhatched siblings
have been kidnapped
explore densely packed worlds full of
puzzles to solve challenges to overcome
and treasure to discover
baby
[Music]
you need a whole cast of strange
creatures and Whimsical characters who
need your help
hatch your rescued siblings and help
raise them to be strong
dig deeper to find new worlds to explore
grow body parts to gain new powers and
discover who stole your siblings and why
jump fly swim strike save your family
from the darkest deaths the mystery is
yours we explore in Cavern of Dreams
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
we'll have a fish in the bottle I have
two bottles in an iPhone foreign
[Music]
whoa
shut up
[Music]
do one more or what's it yeah we
can do one more if I'm not human
[Music]
we came to this Rogue planet to build
something that could save our own
[Music]
underground we discovered Something
Beautiful
where you come in
[Music]
humanity is counting on your
groundbreaker so am I let's get to work
[Music]
thank you
so Donovan seems to be handling his
predicament well all things considered I
mean
the rest this way I do want to help in
any way I can guy you can help by
staying out of it
oh get out of here
[Applause]
there oh thank God I thought I'd lost
you
've been Donovan I heard on the radio
what you're spying on me now
silos
[Music]
wait Power Station out here
hey Donovan
Donovan you copy
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign take us down
thank you
[Music]
my memories
who are you
[Music]
you become my lover and break a heart
yeah
[Music]
turns free from the brightest peed
at loudest color
s
[Music]
meet playdate the little one bit game
console that comes with a crank and 24
free games plus people are making great
new play-date games all the time here
are just three of the latest I'm rakashi
and I'm working on Far Away Fairway at a
golf game with uncovering secrets and
exploring mental health and I can't wait
for everyone to play my name is Gregory
kovas this is cord and we present you um
the written game where you move and
shoot on a beat my name is Spencer
Garwin we game designer of quantum fan
of basketball long-range shooting
high-flying slam dunking hard stuff in
basketball fighting game action
learn more about these games and so many
others at play.date games
[Music]
if all of my interruptions were that
interesting I wouldn't mind them all
that much
but now it's time to get your hands
dirty if you want to travel through
space you have to take risks the cosmic
forces that be have aligned for the
Galaxy Fun kickoff and it's starting
right now
we're all joining forces to help uplift
developers with bold new ideas who are
working to bring their experiments to
life over 200 of you have already
contributed and I'm sure you're seeing
some familiar faces
all funds go directly to developers
making new really really cool [__] and
now it's your turn
put on your goggles roll up your sleeves
and let's make some Galactic chaos by
contributing to the Galaxy fund the
future comes from innovation
I've already seen it all we need now is
you fundraiser is happening right now
till June 24th let's get Atomic baby
power supply and even charging
initiating power saver
power huh well I have just the thing
computer switch to solar let's get some
energy back initializing solar powered
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
generally good
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I don't know
thank you
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
ER build among the clouds
we had forgotten how to gather distant
resources
and we could no longer explore our vast
Horizons
but we never lost that way
no
our problem
Bible
must defend ourselves
we must seek out and defeat our enemies
we must restore the Airborne
[Music]
thank you
there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
building breaking building again we're
always climbing to new heights trying to
find the best ways to express ourselves
you know I built this ship
yes yes with help of course team effort
enough introspection don't want to
become too sentient right let's finish
off with some Cosmic bangers something
to get our blood rushing I picked these
especially for you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's already time
duty calls need to continue looking out
for the best the galaxy has to offer
and although future of play direct is
exiting transmission range the show
isn't over
there's a steam event going on right now
where you can find all of these Cosmic
bangers and more
plus there's a whole other world out
there a wholesome one in fact and trust
me you don't want to miss it let's
steamroll into the future together
milios signing out
see you on the other side dear player
[Music]
foreign